natalia checa nueva es profesora de
primaria y madre de una niña de 11 años
pese a la guerra y la destrucción de su
escuela ha vuelto a dar clases online
para intentar recuperar la normalidad
las de antes y estoy muy chica muy bad
me siento muy feliz de volver a dar
clase de hablar con mis alumnos que los
echaba tanto de menos volver a ver sus
sonrisas es muy importante que sigan
estudiando que no se interrumpa en las
clases
gracias la vuelta a las clases online su
hija verónica no se siente tan sola
estar en contacto con los compañeros de
clase hacer los deberes le ayudan a
lidiar con el miedo de los bombardeos
diarios
no puedo salir a jugar porque es
peligroso siempre están sonando las
sirenas de alarma y tenemos que
refugiarnos ahora he vuelto a ver mis
amigos y hablamos por su plan y tacs
tras la cndh
el 26 de marzo la escuela donde enseñaba
natalia fue atacada por un misil ruso de
las 48 aulas que había en este colegio
sólo dos se han salvado a la destrucción
alina ha venido a ver cómo ha quedado su
escuela bajo las montañas de escombros
por las que camina y hacen ahora sus
recuerdos escolares
y
me pone muy triste pensar que no voy a
poder volver a esta escuela a mi clase y
estar con mis compañeros el último
recuerdo que tengo es que estábamos
haciendo unos pasteles en la clase de
cocina me da tanta pena brawn que get
schooled también es la los ataques a las
escuelas son considerados crímenes de
guerra y esta escuela es un testigo de
una víctima de esta guerra institutos
centros educativos guarderías están
siendo atacados todos los días aquí en
kharkiv rompiendo el futuro de una
generación